welcome to the recruitment mentors
podcast my name
is hisham azuz and we're back with
another installment
of the 15 minutes with a mentor series
where we speak to some of the mentors
from inside
the recruitment mentors community and
we're asking them seven
questions in 15 minutes delighted to be
joined by emma today
uh so emma for those that may not know
who you are if you could introduce
yourself and then we'll get into the
questions
thank you and thank you for having me uh
my name's emma head i am the creative
development director at
beyond the book uh and we specialize in
the creative marketing
and digital industry so i have about 20
years experience as a creative recruiter
um and yes i've gone through uh
obviously this pandemic but also the
credit crunch so
seeing a few up and down in my time i
can imagine
right so first question i want to know
from you what
was your biggest challenge in 2020 how
did you overcome it and what did you
learn from it
okay good question um i think
personally the biggest challenge is i'm
used to being quite
um a high biller someone who hits
targets
and uh you know with the pandemic
there's a lot of things out of your
control so all of a sudden
jobs all coming in and um and therefore
you're not
you know although we've disbanded
targets obviously in the height of
things um
you're not performing or able to perform
as you used to
and i didn't realize i think how much
that affected how i think of myself as a
person so
it's um it kind of i guess knocked me a
bit to fix kind of
you know thinking how um you know how
successful i am so
um and i think you know i have a great
team and
they're lovely but you know when you're
not seeing people or hugging people
it's quite tricky um so you know on my
side in terms of overcoming it
i try to look at success in little
increments so it's not
you know put sales to one side and
thinking you know
what else feels like success when the
world around you is
um yeah so um so you know what else
feels like success
when um you know the sales aren't
happening because
uh you know there's a global pandemic so
um
and so for me i've kind of looked at you
know sort of
um you know linkedin helping people
you know kind of building more brands um
you know i started getting invited on
podcasts such as this i've done sort of
three or four now
and um it's um you know looking at
helping colleagues
you know so it's it was really for me
looking at
you know success isn't about just
hitting a sales target
um it's trying to unpick 20 years of of
doing that so
um so yeah so i i think you know looking
at
what you can influence um and kind of
what can make you feel good still about
yourself if
everything around you um is out of your
control so
i love that yeah no thank you so much
for sharing that
that was great so obviously you're
working from home today
and i want to know from you sort of what
working from home tip could you share
with other recruiters listening to this
that
sort of has had a positive impact on
your own productivity
okay so i think the biggest working from
home tip
is trying to set um
time for certain paths because i am
someone who
um gets easily distracted so my brain
goes here and there and there and there
so
and that can be great when you're
thinking and trying to find
someone for um for a job but when you're
trying to
do booking confirmations and you're
trying to get back to emails and you've
got an inbox
in your inbox you've got a recruiter
inbox you've got your own inbox you know
there's people and messages coming at
you from
all sides i think it can be quite
overwhelming so
um and people don't know if you're ready
or not so you're getting calls at all
times because no one can see if you're
kind of busy so biggest tip for me is
actually my lovely colleague bought me
something which helped me
um and i don't have it um here because i
i made my desk quite fast today but it's
a lovely big
um uh timer so and it's a half an hour
timer
and you turn it so i'm like right i'm
gonna have emails
um i'm gonna crack through my emails
half an hour and i turn it and i think
right when that's done i know
i can move on um so i think it's trying
to be
you know kind of um tight with yourself
and give it you know
specific tasks um and you know kind of
do them at a certain time
because otherwise the day runs away with
you um and so many zooms
and you know and all of a sudden you've
not done those important things so
yeah um i love that i love the i love
the the timer that's great so
yeah i'd be really interested in those
so what over the last 12 months like
what has been the most effective way for
you to
to win business um
well i think you know given the last
year with um
uh yeah it's about treading carefully
and quite sensitively because
the difficulties you don't know if
you're getting in touch with the
business if they've been really hit hard
so it's quite hard to tell from the
outside in um especially for
you know a prospect so um i think in
terms of
um you know trying to identify
businesses and sectors where you think
there's
more of a chance of being busy um so
um so that that is one kind of shifting
the focus of who is busy
in coded world um more so than others
um and and really brand building i mean
i know it's
been been everywhere but um you know
kind of being
on linkedin more connecting with people
i've i've
personally put loads of videos up which
i hadn't before and
um i've had lots of lovely comments back
um so many people
playing you know liking them and so it's
um
and i think it's about brand building
but without an agenda
so um you don't want to be salesy so you
know
you want to be helpful you know you want
to be seen as a thought leader
um somebody you know who knows um
a lot about what the recruitment
industry is like so i think um
so for me you know um it was also being
created with your approach because you
can no longer just phone
um a business and say can i speak to
your hiring manager because
they're in their homes and they're not
going to give you their mobile numbers
so
um so i think for me i i prefer doing
business development over the phone and
that's become more of a challenge so
um so i would you know kind of be um
you know connecting with someone and
then sending them a voice note through
linkedin
um or i've now started doing video notes
um
as well and linkedin to prospects um
because i think if someone can see you
they can hear you they can see your
warmth
um and you come across as genuine um
they're far more likely to
you know kind of um get back to you and
respond back to you so
so that um i think for me is just being
a bit sensitive
you know budging your brand and um being
a bit creative
with how you get in touch with people so
i want to know from you emma what habit
or hobby
did you start in 2020 that you're going
to continue in 2021
oh wow for the first time ever um
i i i got a fictional wow
that as um it's my new favorite toy and
um
because i think you know i'm prone to a
you know good weather exercise
you know like if it's nice whether i'll
go out for a walk if it's not i'd
rather snuggle on a safer um so i've had
to sort of push myself
to kind of get up and move um so
i guess it's more of a habit than a
hobby um
but i have been running up and down
stairs um
we have a loft conversion so we've got
two sets of stairs
so i think the neighbors must think i'm
bonkers but i like running up and down
the stairs to like how many levels you
know can i hit today
um and then we can walk round the house
as well so it's kind of
um you know it's sort of all open so
i'm taking calls and i'm just i'm
walking so um but it's giving me so much
more
energy um so i'm yeah i would say
definitely to get up and move
and the great thing about fitbit it
buzzes to me going
yeah come on yeah yeah
so probably the most probably the most
important question i have for you
which do you think is better the first
coffee
in the morning or the first pint post
work on a friday
wow um i would have to say the first
cup of tea so i like coffee
and like coffee uh i enjoy my coffee but
the first thing in the morning for me
has to be a cup of tea
um and i feel i'm a bit of a tea diver
so i've put this on a post before so
someone if you follow me you'll know
but um i like my um i like my
uh whittard tea with a um oh wow
you know a proper you know kind of all
out go for it with a lid on top keep it
nice and hot
um so i would say yeah
but i will have the coffees comes in the
afternoon to give me a bit of a
um but my tea is my little happy place
so
uh but you know i'm not using the
alcohol we all need that at the end of
the day on friday
but it like one glass and it just you
know because we're not used to drinking
anymore it's like well hey
right so so next question then is it's
slightly different it's a bit more of a
scenario so i
would just be interested to hear how you
would approach this scenario so the
scenario is
a particular business that you've had on
your target client list for a long
period of time over a year
and over that period of time you've had
a number of touch points
with different people in that business
they may have liked or engaged with one
of your videos
you may have connected one of them on
linkedin you may have sent an email you
might have even sent a voice note
to um one of them but through your
candidate network
you managed to to get hold of one of the
hiring managers mobile numbers
and you call them they pick up an answer
and say hello
who is this and i'd be keen to hear how
you would approach that situation
now this is a good question because i
think as i said earlier i
love talking on the phone um and i think
uh i i often do this um
it's it's a bit hard enough to get
mobile numbers but granted when i do
they're like gold dust
um so i think you you know um what i
would normally do is kind of not be
salesy at all
and i'll stay upfront exactly who i am
you don't want to
you know sort of tell them at the end
and then hear their crest falling oh
it's a recruiter
so you know it's um you know i'd say you
know hi
emma um you know sort of we're
connecting on linkedin
um i'm a big fan of your brand
um you know and i'm following what
you've been doing so you're
you're talking about them and so you're
you know sort of um that first few
sentences talk about them and then say
you know um you're a recruiter and you
specialize in
xyz um you know appreciate your
um you may be hiring at the moment and
um you know it would be great to be able
to support you
um in your growth in the coming kind of
uh
months or if there's anything we can do
to help in terms of um
you know we have like giveaways in terms
of like what you know
writing the best job ad or great
questions
so it's sort of thinking you know from
their perspective what would
what would could they take something
away from them called tangibly
um and my biggest thing actually at the
moment is um because i do a lot of
contracts and freelance recruitment is
is talking about ir35 so um
so i would often sort of end on a um
you know sort of i know a lot i've
trained a lot in ir35
um you know if they need any help on
that
you know i've got a short piece that i
can give them
i can sort of talk to their line
managers so you're
keeping it short keeping it a little bit
focused on them so you
sounds like you understand a bit about
their business and then being very
succinct with
what you can help them with um i would
steer clear from chasing a job so i
think you know
people's um barriers go right up
thinking oh it's a recruiter and they
want they've seen i've put out a job and
you know i just want to work the job so
i think it's
you know you're it's thinking of the
long game so you're
trying to build a relationship and
credibility so
let's see that answer yeah that's great
yeah that's good
so final question then
i want you to imagine um i'm a
recruiter and recruiters will be
listening to this and i'm someone that
set my goals for 2021
i'm completely convinced that i'm gonna
have a better year than i did last year
i've written down my goals i'm feeling
motivated
so i just want to sort of hear from you
what would your advice be to me and the
recruiters listening
that you think would give them the best
possible chance
of achieving those goals okay
so i think it's great to have um to be
motivated
and to kind of know where you want to go
but i think your own goals are
are one thing and they're great but i
think the key is to understanding what
your client's goals are
and your prospect skills are so you know
sort of understanding
how then you can align your solutions
to their goals so i think it's um asking
the right questions
when you're speaking to your clients and
i think we're all guilty a little bit of
you know with existing clients oh we
know them we know what they're up to
you know um and we have lovely lovely
conversations with them but you know how
much of the
nitty-gritty and where their business is
going you know
how many of those conversations do you
have thinking you know that their
business
um you know is like it was 6-12 months
ago so
um fine you know asking your client you
know what is their goal
um and thinking well how can then you
help
them achieve their goals um and then
align what you're offering
um to that that client um
and therefore you can become invaluable
and build sort of a long-term
relationship
so yeah it's um yeah i really like that
aligning yourself with your customers
absolutely love that that's awesome
um emma 15 minutes with a mentor
that's it thank you so much thank you
for having me i've
thoroughly enjoyed it so for a friday
morning i was yeah it's all good so
and um yeah i look forward to
being a mentor and if people want to
engage me on the platform then
send me a message